sveglia c'è nessuno pronto
[Musica]
se
qualcuno
berlino è visto qualcuno
vitale
a quanta luce
[Musica]
no berlino non si mangia la zucca
se il proprio come vitale non mangiare
questa zucca merlino st profondo
mangiare le zucche crude
non si può mangiare una zucca di
halloween
basta il proprio uguale a vitale fermo
non si possono mangiare queste zucche
sono crude e poi dobbiamo tagliare per
halloween anche se mi sento un po strano
questa luce mi dà fastidio a te no dove
circe
[Musica]
ecco la
vera questione
non
[Risate]
esiste perché si è arrampicata questi
miei pantaloni che succede perché mi
guardate in modo così strano c'è perché
mi guardasse tutti e due un modo strano
se qualcosa che non va mi sembra tutto
ok trame questo però mi sento un po
strano
[Musica]
questo per cosa
che cosa significa
[Musica]
o no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
[Risate]
perfetto ora si sta molto meglio
[Musica]
anita
anita tutto bene che ho sentito urlare
la
sanità
ma qui non c'è
sarà uscita poi perché tutto buio qui
[Musica]
chi è questa chi sei tu che cosa ci fai
qui ma
non riesco a capire se questa è anita o
no cari
sveglia c'è nessuno pronto
sveglia
sta dormendo profondamente
ti senti svegliati contessa
contesto sveglie di monnezza che ha
vestito un po come una contessa niente
non si sveglia proverò ad aprire le
tende così magari entra più luce si
sveglierà finalmente un po di luce
apriamo anche questa ora sì che abbiamo
aperto le tende e sia un po di luce
beh
è chiaro
che non mi chiudo lo chiudeva bene scusa
non pensavo che dessero così fastidio se
sto chiudendo e confuso tende vedi va
meglio adesso come
e perché ho sentito urlare sono corso
subito da te che ho trovato qui spese
che provato a svegliarti non ti
svegliavi allora ho per te le tende che
hai quel vestito da contessa e ti dà
fastidio la luce è tutto questo
arredamento che hai fatto qui intorno
che cosa che è successo nel tempo
mortale devo tornare al mio sogno
e tu come stai rubare il mio spazio
cane mortale portati tu subito dal mio
spazio
addio per sempre
mortale carne mortale ma forse non si
sente bene infatti la vedo un po pallidi
na magari ha solo bisogno di mangiare
limita che ne pensi se ti preparo
qualcosa da mangiare magari ti tira su
un po il morale magari ti sentirai
meglio
[Musica]
come rosi continuare a disturbare il mio
sono
vai via e porta via anche il cane
mortali non ti preoccupare
ho capito tutto ti preparerò il tuo
piatto preferito lo mangiano subito ti
preoccupare è proprio
il mio piatto preferito
non ricordo più quale il mio piatto
preferito da umana mortale so solo che
ho molta sete adesso
[Musica]
che schifo hay que en e mortale è come
se mi stessi dimenticando che ha un
piano ci sono eccome se qualcuno
qualcosa stesse cercando di contro i
marroni forse è meglio se mi guardo allo
specchio e vedo se sono ancora io eccolo
qua
[Musica]
e ma perché non si vede niente che cosa
significa questo lasciate un mi piace
per aiutarmi a vita eccomi qua ho
preparato un piatto preferito
spaghetti aglio olio e peperoncino
pronti
[Musica]
spaghetti
aglio olio
e peperoncino
no non li voglio maggiori to ok
ma come mangiarli io ma tu non mi lasci
mai mangiare le due cose non c'è nessun
problema è più rimangio volentieri è
tranquilla ma sei sicura che non li vuoi
assaggiare un pochettino non ti
avvicinare
mancino come piace a terra no no non li
vogliono allontanati dai assaggio poco
è sembrato barboni
figura che non li vuoi figura
quando lui io ma davvero non li vuole
assaggia almeno una forchettata guarda
ma dopo no no
ma che stai dicendo ma berlino perché
stai provando a proteggerne allontana
l'idea detto questo cane mortale a
proteggere il suo
votarti ora ti porterò
che cosa stai facendo
mi sono nascosto adesso posso continuare
a mangiare tranquillo
chissà perché è unita si arrabbia per
quel modo forse perché voleva mangiare
gli spaghetti a priori offerti e ha
detto di non li voleva continuava a
ripetermi che voleva mordermi non
capisco sinceramente
vesevo
profetici
nascosto
un formaggio
di pecora
una
selezioni di pensare e di
fatto il cammino
stai ma dove
[Musica]